[Music]
chuck we're back
yes we are and this was interesting
there are certain things that we just
experience in our lives and never even
think to question it
true because it's in our everyday life
and and and and some things you don't
want to know the answers
that's different some things are just
that's left unexplained
unknown i'm not i'm not gonna mess with
not gonna go there
no no this one you ask a simple question
why does ice float
right have you ever asked that i have
you have okay i have yeah i mean because
when you think about it it's water
but you're putting it in water yeah
liquid it's water liquid in
water right it's water and water so and
usually when you cool something down
it shrinks okay it becomes
more dense tell me about it
so it becomes more dense and so you
would think
that a cooler version of some liquid
would be you know if you shrink the same
mass down to a smaller volume it's more
dense
that right all ice cubes would sink to
the bottom of your glass
as a matter of fact in certain parts
of the oceans i'm gonna
where you have what they call um oh god
now i forget the name of it it just
it was just on the tip of my tongue but
the coldest water
stays at the bottom of the ocean yeah
we're not there yet
oh we're actually going to talk about
that yes
oh sweet oh my gosh we're totally going
there okay forget about that
okay all right all right so so
a peculiar thing happens to water when
it changes
state okay a change of state means you
go from liquid to solid solid to gas get
so we have water and there it is
when it freezes the water
molecule in order to freeze takes up
more volume
than does the water molecule in a liquid
state
so the water expands by about 10 percent
nice okay and roughly you can think
about that as
if you are if you expand 10 and you go
back
into your liquid you will bob with about
10 of your volume
above the water okay and 90
below so just put put an ice cube in
your glass
it's easier to see this if it's in a
cube shape rather than in those crescent
shapes or other things but if you take a
cube and put it in there
ten percent will be above the water and
ninety percent will be below
all right hold on
oh okay all right
okay okay all right i just happen to
have a glass of water here
oh you do and are you is your ice in it
are they cubes oh my goodness look at
that that's
awesome yes this is a cube okay okay
and you just see it's got like a little
surface you can't see it but
it's got a little surface because the
top part is clear i don't know why
but it's just like you said it's like
it's bobbing up yeah it's stopping
but most of it is below yeah so check a
little bit about
it's not happening because i said so
it's happening because this is how the
universe works
no no you're a wizard stop lying
now here's an interesting fact if you
take that same glass of water
with that one ice cube in it and fill it
as much as you possibly can
so that not another drop can go in it
without spilling over the edge
right if you do that okay the ice will
be sitting
above that level above the lip of the
glass
right and you might be worried oh my
gosh i better get a coaster
because when this melts it's going to
overflow
but no when it melts it's going to take
up the volume
that it's already displacing in the
water itself and it's not going to get
any higher
than it currently is right this is
why the
arctic ice sheets in the arctic
so where santa claus is right it is ice
that is
floating on the water
in the future where global warming melts
the entire northern cap
when that happens it will not that alone
will not increase the sea levels of the
world
because the ice is already floating in
the bathtub
of that water that's correct so the ice
you need to worry about
is the ice that's on land oh that runoff
the runoff okay
that ice you melt that you're directly
adding watercolor that's on greenland
and
primarily greenland and antarctica so
that then
starts flooding the oceans and raising
raising the sea levels okay so
but by the way uh 232 feet if that were
to happen
oh thank you for that number yeah i
think i tweeted once that if you if you
do that then the water level will go up
to the
left elbow of the statue of liberty yeah
the one that's holding
uh i think it's the declaration of
independence just in her arm
and yeah and that basically you lose
manhattan and basically every other
coastal city
of which where you find most of the
great cities of the world
are on the water's edge so anyhow so
so so that's why ice floats but there's
more going on here you could delay
the freezing of the ice it freezes at 32
degrees or zero degrees celsius
you can make it freeze at like one
degree below zero
if you put it under pressure okay yeah
and it's good
so it gets colder and it says i want to
freeze i have to get bigger i have to
get bigger i'm not letting you
so then it doesn't it doesn't change the
state okay
but if you keep taking the temperature
lower and lower
under pressure the isis says the ice
says
okay and i will expand no matter what
you're doing and
boom pipes break yeah
okay so i don't know why i'm hap i don't
know why i'm so happy
i'm a homeowner what am i talking about
that's disastrous you're happy that you
you now understand the full dynamics of
that so it would be very
hard for ice at 32 degrees to break a
pipe
because the pipes are made of typically
they're made of copper or some
strong metal and so it'll keep it
squeezed down and
say no you're not freezing at 30 no
you're not going to let you freeze at 30
degrees
no not at 29. oh 25 degrees
and it and it is stronger than
the pipes and you just break the pipes
and by the way
at that moment all the pipes are frozen
there's no leakage
when do you have leakage when the
temperature goes up again
and then the ice melts out of the path
and then the water
flies ugh so the
the the act of broken pipes in most
cases
is not the moment where you get the leak
because the ice is there the ice is
there plugging the pipes
it's later on when the ice moves out of
the way
so so this is the power of freezing ice
now last point i want to make is well
how about the density of water just as
water does it change density
yes it does okay as you cool water
it takes up slightly less and less
volume
hardly noticeable if you're just
swimming in it or just looking just like
and if you heat water it takes up
slightly more volume
and a lot of the increased sea level
rise
in the future of global warming is
simply because the oceans are warmer
and they're warmer they they take up you
know let's say it's one percent more
depth
right but you come but what is one
percent more depth in the middle of the
ocean where it's three miles deep
okay if it's one percent more depth by
the time you get to the shoreline
you have flooding right okay so let's
cool the water it gets colder and colder
and colder
it begins to shrink well at some point
that has to turn around because
eventually it's going to become
ice where it's bigger there is a point
where ice is at its densest and it's
three degrees celsius
really okay so you so you cool water at
the surface
it's denser than the water below it and
so that cool water drops
and it goes to the bottom okay
and it stays there you keep trying to
cool water at the top and it goes down
to the bottom but what happens now
you're cooling water now the water is
2 degrees celsius or 1 degree celsius it
begins to stay
on top then it hits 0 degrees celsius it
freezes
on top on top keeping
the three degree water at the bottom
right
preserving all aquatic
life over the winter time that's why you
don't have bird's eye frozen fish
once the uh once the lake freezes
just like the lake if ice sank
oh my gosh you would freeze lakes from
the bottom up you through that top layer
would go to the bottom and
slowly but surely all the fish would be
swimming
in an ever thinner layer of water until
you just go and scoop them all
up and that's the last fish that would
ever exist in that lake
oh what a what a bear's dream
no they're hibernating they're missing
this that's true yeah so
so this feature of
water protects life
over the winter aquatic life over the
winter wow
and once you form the ice layer on the
top it actually insulates the bottom
you get really cold on top but that does
that how long will that take to transmit
through
a thick layer of ice it takes a long
time by then it's daytime
compared to night or spring has come and
so you
rarely if ever do you end up freezing an
entire lake
and it's because of this property of
water that ice floats
the ice is less dense than water that is
amazing
and it's it's pretty cool that this this
becomes like its own little closed
ecosystem where
the ice freezes on top insulates the
water beneath it so
that all the life is protected it's
protected that's amazing
it's basically it so this is a feature
of this fact about
water the water molecule one other thing
it's what enables you to ice skate
okay because the reverse is true so i if
i have an ice cube
and it's sitting at let's say 30 degrees
okay right
and it's frozen so minus one let's say
celsius if i squeeze it
if i squeeze it under pressure i'm
trying to put it into a smaller volume
ice won't let you do that right but
if i press it really hard what's the
only way the ice can respond to you
to go into a smaller volume it's got to
become water it's got to become water so
you can
squeeze melt something even at
subfreezing
oh my god that's
that's how you get the great ice cube
there no
ice spheres for drinking scotch
what you just said they take a copper
press
and i'm too excited about this i'm sorry
this is this
bar information that you're sharing i
know i know now what's up now we're
talking about scotch and drinking i'm
like oh my god
uh and you don't even have your scotch
voice today right now exactly
yeah exactly yeah you want another
definitely need a little scotch that's
what i'm saying
when you're skating on ice okay
the blade is the way it's it's sharpened
is it has a very sharp edge on one side
and on the other
on the left and on the right hand side
so you go on an edge and skaters know
about this on your inside edge
or on the outside edge that is a lot of
pressure we got to do a whole other
explainer video on force and pressure
but that pressure is so high
that it actually melts the ice in place
and the
skate glides on a bead of water wow
that's great
that's why that's why ice is slippery on
ice skates
yeah so so yeah i mean that same premise
you just
um um um demonstrate it
when you get a they make spheres of ice
for drinking i love
ice spheres yeah ice spheres and they
use for some reason copper i don't know
why
but they used copper or brass one or the
other
and they just put the ice in the sphere
and they let the brass
it's a big weight it's a brass weight or
a copper weight
and it just presses down on the ice and
then the ice melts into a ball
that is so cool oh okay all right so
they take
okay so to shaping the sphere from the
pressure on a shape that's not a sphere
that's right okay yeah so under pressure
yes it will melt under pressure it melts
yet yet when you relieve the pressure it
freezes instantly it freezes right
because it's
because it's the it's the below freezing
temperature that you started with
exactly and then you just have a bit a
literal ball of ice
okay chuck i don't go to many bars i've
never seen this i trust that in your bar
hopping this is something
feature okay i'm gonna have to i'm gonna
have to get you out man
i gotta get more off i'm gonna have to
get you out of the house
all right so that's that's it chuck
that's uh ice is less dense than
water nice i'm always fascinated how we
end up in these great places from
something
so seemingly um mundane
as a cube of ice or ice melting
and next time we do this we got to do
this with one of your spheres of ice and
i want to do a whole explainer video
with you and your scotch voice
oh absolutely not a problem
no i don't i'll start on it right now
right now
all right chuck always good to have you
always a pleasure neil degrasse tyson
here for star talk
keep looking up
you